Okay, Ryan, let's do it.
- Oh, yeah!
- Good luck.
- Okay.
- You got this.
You got this.
You got this, buddy.
[wheel beeping]
- Whammy!
No.
- All right.
Wheel of Musical Impressions.
- Oh!
- Okay, you got this.
- ♪ Wheel of
Musical Impressions ♪
♪ Wheel of
- Now in this challenge, you're
gonna get a singer or a band,
and then you have to
sing a song
while doing
an impression of them.
Let's see what you get.
- Beyoncé!
Beyoncé!
- Uh-oh.
Whoa!
- You got Timberlake.
- Oh, all right.
- All right.
All right, all right.
- "Poison," lil'
Bell Biv DeVoe.
- All right.
- You got it, you got it.
- ♪ That girl is poison
- Give him some of the JT,
Timberlake type of jam.
[cheers and applause]
- Let's try it like this.
[funky music]
- Oh, oh!
- Okay, okay, okay.
- Oh!
- Okay!
♪
Oh!
- Right here, Ryan.
- ♪ Girl, I must warn you
♪ I sense something strange
in my mind ♪
- Oh, my God!
- ♪ Oh, yeah, yeah
- All right, JT!
All right, JT!
- ♪ Situation is serious
- Yeah!
- ♪ Let's cure it 'cause
we're running out of time ♪
- Take it to the bridge.
- ♪ Oh
Yeah!
♪ It's driving me
out of my mind ♪
- Hold on now.
- ♪ That's why it's hard
♪ For me to find
♪ Can't get it out of my head
♪ Miss her, kiss her,
love her ♪
♪ That girl is poison
♪ Yeah
- Whoo!
- ♪ Don't want to cry no more
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah
- Oh, that's just...
- ♪ Poison
♪ Oh, yeah!
♪ All I want you to do
is be my poison ♪
- Whoa!
- Oh, okay!
- Whoo!
- Okay!
- ♪ My poison
♪ Poison
- Yes!
- ♪ Ooh
♪ Yeah
All I'm trying to say is
all I want you to do
is be my...
♪ Poison
- Whoo!